te la senti ragazzi benvenuti a che sono
vita di fv soci siamo su un episodio un
po particolare perché da quando avevo
fatto l'episodio dedicato al nonno ciak
e quindi ho fatto tutti venivano uno
shock
oggi vorrei fare tutti i livelli con
steve l'uomo poco bahamas così chiare le
rock le easy a 24 che siamo inventato
lui questo stile qua sapete colori e
sparami tanto arpioni forse prima non
c'era sono vivo non solo anche come
questo è veramente una cazzata muoio
servizio di via ballao molto easy laica
boss vediamo questo clima che rischio
perché infatti david mills il gol
oddio ma come ha gia schilling che mi sa
che la loro anche già fatto in realtà
non lo so è però questa discesa roma
ricordo va a ras ei
sei molto bella e va a nice day anche te
amico mio grazie attacco da la la
madonna
qualcosa mi dice che questo non è un
livello conflitto la madonna fu richiamo
l'ha fatta dalla ragazza
b come non c'entra niente estivo lo
hanno fatto a posto livello
red cau
[Musica]
è vista con 6 e passa al 4 maggio essere
con voi questo video non uscirai 4
maggio ovvero panieri a questo è stato
uno dei primi poco jump forse io non li
ho mai fatti poco perché non mi fanno
impazzire
alla fine devi solo superare il 10 dei
muri quindi non c'è niente di così
challenge oso però oggi a livello
dedicato a stili facciamo nemmeno uno
ma io c'ero noris ti prende dal giorno
di sicuro non la domenica gli happy york
chuck norris ok come diavolo di passare
lì quello dopo ancora più difficile
ragazzi ok ce l'ho fatta non so cosa mi
è crollato pesantemente non pensavo
proprio che osama ho ammazzati tutti
aspetta aspetta che non so come brand
cielo madonna che porta ok palau
spacebar ko ma d'oro nella prova neutre
e da una soddisfazione incredibile nei
momenti di stress questo livello è un
toccasana
pazzesco ok vi giuro nei libri nei
momenti di stress e giocare a roma
sarebbe veramente incredibile oddio
robin i miei due vice perfetto con una
cattiveria mostro tante fido è finito
ragazzi va bene basketball dunk
basketball dante bellissimo beschi bocca
anche ko
minchia only for ninja se io sono poi
dei pani proviamo madonna questo lodo
difficilissimo ragazzi dovevo prendere
velocità già prima e non l'ho presa
quindi bama lo aspetto
ap estate proprio il piedistallo eyed
peas da marcus sono uscito ho già rotto
il livello e non ho fatto niente
vai giù per cortesia devo riuscire ad
arrivare alla fine però come faccio vado
semplicemente avanti ma non riesco muoio
se ti facciamo fatto prima che sono a me
era un modo veramente giusto sono muoio
proprio non riesco let's go
e stata senza la moneta ma fa niente
mortal kombat fai la madonna blog lo fai
ti vuol mortal kombat meravigliosamente
fantastico dovete sapere che io me la
cavo mortal kombat non si non si vede
che tutto nelle palle iodato preferivo
la morte san siro claudio cascato 18
faccia outing non ho fatto niente è
cascato 18 lui
madonna non si compete la bellissima
cosa vuoi ma cosa vuoi
non ho capito come sono morto ma fa
niente
[Musica]
dallo stato ucciso su ca questa la mia
patate però era finito lì ma dai ma va a
cagare errori perché io voglio sempre un
secondo prima della fine
incredibile roma gioiello difficile
ormai ci ha preso veramente gusto
stilisti livelli non so come mai ma gol
non avevo dato veramente freddo si ben
poco fa in un altro tipo di prima a
napoli stickman però non ho la falce ai
a chiamare nel culo pro vivo
sono vivo e la madonna che schivata ho
una faccia e le verità non ha proseguo
beccate questo lo uso come arma
benissimo
tiziana suo uso come arma ragazzi c'è il
mago meteorite sono vivi possono il
nostro vivo sono vivo
non so come ho fatto posto finale non lo
vedo
ho sentiti io l'ho colpito aiuto aiuto
aiuto sono morto next level sluyter i
criteri io ho che senso o mio dio ho
vinto però è evidente lo superare sapete
bene che siamo capaci tutti gli ammassi
dice che la cosa ti manca volata
ok lo metterà non provo superando
ragazza devo saltare subito dopo
praticamente dove centrarlo devo andare
al 100 preciso e poi di saldare un
casino abnorme ma torna se non avessi te
la tua testata
esco dai bafana perfetto con la spaccata
alla lisa fusco album doge tre stage
questi g prestige non ho capito niente
di quello che è successo mandiamo devo
scrivere
devo schivare gli arpioni così che mi
arrivano ma giocava lo schivato non so
come a posto schivate in starnuto saluti
né ma non lo so
e stato inutile come ho detto che ti un
effetto sonoro dio che santis che in
quel momento gianpi grazie schivate in
starnuto l'importante aver vinto
comunque ragazzi abbiamo capito due cose
da poco dal po dall'uomo poco il primo
che gli archivi si staccano come niente
e il secondo è che un ladro di gioielli
perché sono tutti livelli dove devi dove
di rubare i gioielli senza un motivo
vabbè sono un ladro di gioielli vadano
tutto a posto non mi ha preso vivo morto
o dei meravigliosi si mostrano molto a
noi non dovevo prendere il gioiello devo
prenderla moneta malaschini ladro di
monete se sente meno via po il focus sul
gioiello tutto convinto invece una via
una sega
proprio lui cosa cosa vedo no vabbè
ragazzi bellissimo sto male
bellissimo di un uomo a chiudere
adotterà testata il cubano e che poi mi
si spaccano a destra mi stai trovando
invece aiuto aiuto mi chiama spaccato
tutto sono morto se supermario fosse
stato così violento ha citato i livelli
o sul primo sono curioso fanno finiamolo
l'ultimo ragazzi questo è l'ultimo è
colui migliore immagino a vedersi
veramente quello migliore
vediamo dove ci porta regalo perfetto
perfetto allora prenderemo il corno
spetta trovato la stella
[Musica]
bellissimo super mario bros export
metroid si vabbè peccato perché speravo
ci fossero tutti i livelli però ma
sapete che vi dico faccio l'ultimo come
imposto perché non ho fatti tanti e io
pensavo fossero solo impossible
e invece pare che mi sono scelto l'unica
cosa che non mi dovevo scegliere
prodotti dop sposo che non sono altro
che potevo smettere lividi l'arresto
però la dimostrazione di pagine e non fa
questi ragazzi hanno livelli solo con
steve
spero che vi sia piaciuto e come solito
se non sono questi iscrivetevi e noi ci
vediamo ma è cascato il telecomando nomi
che scava da un anno almeno sarà un
segno dai ragazzi
[Musica]